the Rog phone 5 was released in March of
2021 and not even a yearly the Asus has
brought the next duration of the
flagship gaming smartphone to the lineup
and boy I gotta tell you this phone
knocks everything out of the park when
it comes to gaming and then some today
I'll be unboxing the Rog phone 6 Pro and
give you my first impressions on this
gaming performance and other things
let's get into it
[Music]
what's up fellow Geeks my name is Inyo
and if you're new to the channel welcome
to key culture we cover tons of amazing
stuff like Tech Toys entertainment and
more so do subscribe and leave us a like
if this content tickles your fancy now
the main box for the Rog phone 6 Pro is
Sleek and futuristic it kind of reminds
me of armored call for some reason so
let's open this up be careful okay we
got a card here which is for the AR
experience Asus mentioned which I'll
leave for you guys to experience for
yourselves and the main phone
wow nice the main phone it looks and
feels very Evangelion Evangelion like
real Ray ayanami Vibes it has a sleep
pack and the only thing that will
attract smudges are the camera and it's
a little display panel which I think
plays animations and we got other stuff
the cases down here
with some instructions and at the bottom
we have the charging head and the
charging cable which doesn't want to
come out the charging cable so now let's
talk about the phone this thing packs a
6 000 milliamp hour dual cell battery
with a 65 watt charger that goes zero to
full in 42 minutes the camera at the
back uses a Sony sensor and shoots
videos up to 8K 24fps and 4K and 60 and
30 FPS it has a Snapdragon 8 plus gen 1
chip packed with an overclock adrenal
730 GPU that according to Asus delivers
10 faster CPU and GPU performance and 30
more battery efficiency the main screen
is a Samsung AMOLED display tuned by Rog
themselves and goes to a Max refresh
rate of 165 Hertz with a touch sampling
rate of up to 720hz and in 23
millisecond touch latency to put it
simply it's damn smooth and Asus was
kind enough to send us all these
accessories the aeroactive cooler and
the cool 93 Gamepad and you all know how
to spoilers amongst many other cool
things I'm just going to touch on a few
that stood out to me in the time I've
had it the phone has two USBC portal
charging one on the bottom right and the
other on the side and it has a 3.5
millimeter audio jack which you don't
see very often but the one thing that
stood out to me the most are its
speakers as the audio rich guy for the
channel let me tell you God it was
lovely first blast sound staging is wide
and clear thanks to its two symmetrical
five magnet 12x16 super linear speakers
powered by a series logic
cs-35l45 mono amplifiers on a consumer
level these are really amazing to have
around because even at the lower volumes
the sound is still wide clear and deep
so you can expect even greater when you
blast it and of course the sexiest thing
about this phone is this Rog P AMOLED
display look at that that comes with
several pre-loaded animations Asus even
added 60 more compared to its previous
iterations and you can even download or
create your own animations it's honestly
a great conversation piece and will
definitely turn hits as you turn yours
to pick up a call or game with it's a
great looking phone overall and gaming
wise which we'll be covering in a video
against the blackshop 5 Pro so far it
handles heat management really well with
its game Cool 6 cooling system that
spreads heat evenly across the phone and
if you get the aeroactive cooler you
wouldn't need to worry about overheating
at all honestly but this being First
Impressions video with the amount of
time I've had with it it's safe to say
that there hasn't been any deal breaking
bugs or terrible features on the phone
yet but also take into account that
there will be more updates in the future
so I wouldn't worry about anything too
much if I were you the Asus Rog phone 6
Pro is definitely a handily made phone
with Gamers consent in mind in terms of
heat distribution ergonomics and mindful
details like the side USBC port and a
ton of accessories readily available to
amp up your gaming experience it's
really something that I personally am
looking forward to so that's all we have
for this video if you have any questions
leave them in the comment section down
below and I'll do my best to get to them
remember to follow us on all of our
socials and if you like this video leave
a like And subscribe to our Channel we
have a ton of content coming your way
this is inio and I'll catch up with you
all soon
foreign